i'm going to show you some footage in a
moment of a man that murdered olivia
the clearest image is yet of the man who
police say shot and killed a
nine-year-old girl in her own home
described as callous and toxic by the
detectives hunting him these images of
the masked gunman were captured even as
olivia pratt corbell laid dying in her
mother's arms
the gunman is wearing a black padded
jacket
a black balaclava with a peak
black gloves
and also has dark trainers with
distinctive white soles
he is described as approximately five
foot seven tall
and of slim build
this is the man we are hunting for
this is the way the gunman ran down king
seath avenue as he made his escape he'd
just forced his way into olivia's home
shooting her mother cheryl through the
wrist as she tried to stop him that same
bullet hitting olivia in the chest
fatally wounding her he also shot his
intended target 35 year old joseph knee
before running away
it was when he turned off king's heath
avenue onto finch lane that the cctv
cameras picked him up dressed all in
black with a balaclava but wearing those
distinctive white sold trainers
then just 50 meters later he was
captured on camera a second time turning
right into berryford road continuing to
use people's backyards and gardens to
make good his escape
detectives say they now know that two
guns were used in the attack both were
discharged a minimum of five shots in
total were fired
it is beyond comprehension how anyone
could protect or harbor a man who's
responsible for killing a nine-year-old
child
this man is toxic
he is toxic to our communities
and if you're protecting him he's toxic
to you and your family
further cctv released by police shows a
man close to the shooting just before it
happened they want to speak to him
urgently
as the police search continued olivia's
family away from the cameras came to
look at the tributes that have been
brought here to show the love and
support of the community
a community that has so far provided
officers with a number of names and
potential leads but not yet it seems the
vital piece of information that could
bring olivia's killer to justice
fraser moored sky news liverpool